mettez-vous à la queue leu vient de
changer
[Applaudissements]
là c'est terminé bien entendu
je vais le récupérer mais attendez je
rappelle que tous les smartphones ils
seront tombés se terminant donc ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
benaïne
et vous allez devoir prendre des risques
[Applaudissements]
d'accord
je rappelle bien sûr que tout portable
dans mon cul
[Applaudissements]
incroyable
venez voir alors venez voir parce que je
crois vraiment qu'il y a pratiquement
une égalité
bonjour bonjour
au final toutes les deux avec moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais faire attention j'ai pas pouvoir
tout accueillir
allez merci allez mon Clément
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il a un petit peu humide
c'est vrai qu'ils sont un peu sales
[Applaudissements]
la finale
c'est maintenant la finale la finale je
veux du sel hydroalco Benjamin je vais
te demander d'aller t'asseoir parce que
tu ne fais pas partie de la finale
malheureusement j'ai demandé à Sophia
benahim devenir fais la finale à 3 je
rappelle le principe merci
du public
si je perds
que Sophia ou Valérie gagne elle
partiront avec le smartphone le 14 de la
marque à la pomme croquis
d'aller jouer toutes les deux on va tram
est conscience c'est pas du tout ce que
ça veut dire
en tout cas les chéris
ça sera en deux points OK
qui démarre tu veux commencer chérie
c'est parti allez vas-y mon cœur
[Applaudissements]
qui tombe terminera dans la culotte
Delphine
[Applaudissements]
bonjour pour le premier point
alors je prends le premier point
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je te dis
spectateurs
le smartphone le 14 le 14 fucking in
English bear
et à une personne du public
et je vais demander en public
quand on est avec moi
ce chant ah bah non
non
[Applaudissements]
je t'offre quoi qu'il arrive à toi le
smartphone
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant
maintenant
que Sofia est hors du jeu
nous allons pouvoir
chanter
ah bah non
[Applaudissements]
ici
solennellement que si je remporte
et bien monte mon téléphone ira à l'un
d'entre vous dans le public
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas remporté le poids faut que
je joue
[Applaudissements]
arrête de jouer maintenant
je rappelle
ce smartphone à son fils
tu en as besoin
est-ce que vous repartez avec le
portable quand même si vous gagnez
pas avec ça
les gens sont contre toi tu le vois bien
pas avec ça tu vas te faire du mal pour
rien
je rappelle que si benhalim remporte
point elle repartira
avec le smartphone sous le bras quand
vous narguant
en disant non toi tu n'as pas eu toi non
plus toi non plus toi dans ton cul
et oui
ne me parle pas sur ce ton
alors je vais vous dire la vérité
ce qui me caractérise depuis des années
des années c'est la galanterie et jamais
je ne passerai avant Valérie Valérie tu
vas tirer en premier pour l'éternité
[Applaudissements]
vous savez qu'il n'y a qu'une chose à
dire qu'une chose à faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la merde
le public a toujours raison et je vais
poser une question simple
est-ce que pour vous
cette performance est homologuée
[Applaudissements]
il comprend
[Rires]
ici on a ce qu'on appelle
un bois de Formica un bois de Formica
[Rires]
on est sur du plexi les règles sont
claires article 7
façons que ce soit le plexi c'est écrit
où ça c'est écrit dans le règlement
qu'on va sortir s'il vous plaît
de quelques façons que ce soit le plexi
[Applaudissements]
bles
[Rires]
[Musique]
vous avez vu jusqu'à la fin
qu'est-ce qu'elle vient de vous dire vos
excuses vous les avez dans le cucul
[Musique]
plus loin
s'il vous plaît tu sais que un jour ou
l'autre les gourous finissent par tomber
les gourous
tu peux venir voir je vais demander au
public j'ai demandé à quelqu'un du
public de venir ici
monsieur j'ai confiance en Lui monsieur
soyez honnête monsieur regardez-moi dans
les yeux
comment tu t'appelles je m'appelle
Jordan Jordan alors Jordan s'il te plaît
Jordan regarde tu vois alors
alors si je regarde bien
mais il est en train de lui dire que
c'est pas bon
[Applaudissements]
pour s'affranchir son honnêteté Jordan
part avec le smartphone 14
[Applaudissements]
qui nous regardent parce que c'est une
leçon de vie
[Rires]
l'honnêteté fait toujours
toujours et ça doit être dans ta vie
Jordan tous les jours maintenant tu
prendras cet exemple tu dis tu dragues
j'étais honnête un jour et ça m'a souri
c'est vrai l'honnêteté paie toujours
Jordan et tous ceux qui nous regardent
d'ailleurs chez eux regardez Jordan on
est l'exemple parfait merci Jordan
il y en a un deuxième alors il y en a un
deuxième alors vous allez laisser votre
téléphone ici maintenant parce que
le téléphone pose problème sachez que
actuellement on a appelé on est il y a
l'avare là qui est en train de
voilà la vidéo surveillance est en train
de voir ce qu'on peut faire alors
j'aimerais bien que la prochaine fois
Cyril jouons à ce jeu parce que nous
allons y rejouer vous voulez avoir les
règles je veux avoir les règles dans le
barco imprimer dès le départ du début
Jordan a gagné son smartphone 14
maintenant il en reste un deuxième
c'est très simple
pour gagner ce deuxième smartphone je
rajoute une règle dans ce jeu
on appelle un alinéa
et que le téléphone va en enfer
comme il le mérite d'ailleurs
son iPhone oui je l'offrirai à quelqu'un
du public
et oui pour
ce jeu je vais demander
à Madame
je bouge pas d'arrêter de me regarder je
ne bougerai pas je te regarde comme vous
savez les Français savent ce que vous
êtes en train de faire
et les Français vous jugent à tout
instant bene
si vous voulez une France de la
corruption
une France de la triche Benaim la France
qu'on aime pas oh non on n'aime pas
cette
[Musique]
autre de ses propres turpitudes
[Rires]
me regarde que Benaim termine en enfer
chez Funhouse
[Rires]
près de moi j'ai besoin que tu sois là
[Applaudissements]
cinéma olala
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comme quoi le corps du bien gagne
toujours à la fin
le corps du mal
a encore créé souvent Dieu
c'est riche
et oui
l'amour la paix
triomphe toujours
excusez-moi vous avez quand même
conscience que vous applaudissez un
escroc en
[Rires]
qui en a vraiment envie
je vais vous dire pour que tout le monde
soit content c'est Valérie Benaim qui va
choisir le gagnant mais non
j'arrive jusqu'au bout Valérie Benaim
vous allez choisir le gagnant de ce
deuxième smartphone
vous allez dire un numéro entre 1 et 50
il y a plus que 50 personnes je vais pas
faire un numéro entre 1 et 150
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu nous appelles dans la semaine
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 18
42 43 44 45 46 47 48 49 50 50
91 92 93 94 95 96 97 98 99
[Applaudissements]
juste prix
Le Millionnaire comment ça va ma chérie
ça fait tellement longtemps c'est grâce
à mon ami c'est grâce à mon ami que je
suis venu te voir pour ce qu'on a une
belle histoire
je connais depuis longtemps mais
pour les missions pour des émissions
merci merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jamais ça n'arrivera ici jamais jamais
on arrivera ici je t'en prie je te le
jure jamais le mal triomphe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
je te jure
est-ce que alors c'est toi qui va
décider est-ce que j'offre un smartphone
à benime quand même d'accord même si
c'est le camp du mal
allez un cœur
merci Monsieur bébé d'amour je t'aime je
t'aime